depuis l'âge de 9 ans d'accord on m'a
expliqué que j'étais noir et que j'ai 4
inférieure vous ne vivez pas l'espace
public de la même façon lorsque vous
êtes une personne de couleur noire parce
que lorsque vous êtes une personne de
couleur noire vous pouvez vous faire
cracher dessus mais ma la télévision et
les autres taureaux ne disent rien
zemmour il serait noir il pourrait pas
tenir ce discours
vous prenez une personne noire vous
mettez à la télévision qui tient un
discours comme ça sur une personne
blanche
cette personne ne reste pas deux
secondes à la télé c'est ça la réalité
en plus lorsque vous êtes humilié en
tant que personnel
on vous demande d'accepter si jamais
vous revendiquez et vous dénoncez ne
vous comprends pas vous fini par croire
que vous avez un problème vous c'est
extrêmement triste mais c'est la société
dans laquelle nous vivons
et vous savez lorsque vous êtes une
personne - vous avez déjà intégré depuis
très longtemps que vivaient dans ce
monde là parce que c'est ça en fait les
gens ne se rendent pas compte quand vous
êtes une fan je pense que vous avez
intégré aussi que peut-être que vous
allez dire quelque chose on va pas vous
prendre au sérieux que l'on prendrait au
sérieux un homme parce qu'en fait ceux
qui sont dominés sont conscients de
cette domination
mais lorsque vous le dénoncer mais
quelques pains vous n'êtes pas bien
compris on vous prend pour un rebelle
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on vous
demande de changer je pense que toute
personne blanche devrait se réfléter
réfléchir à savoir est-ce que parfois je
ne réfléchis pas comme une personne
blanche